1912 and in Washington DC this member
of United States censors office is busy
with Pancho via incident West
Point graduate since nineteen
three his name is Douglas MacArthur on
military expedition to Veracruz Mexico
he's captain MacArthur and among his
associates is another young unknown to
win Fame during not too far distant Wars
youth from Germany named Franz von Papen
among many to recognize MacArthur's military
brilliance in First World War is General John
Black Jack Pershing after winning laurels
on French battlefields MacArthur comes home
and November 20th 1919 now Brigadier
General he's head of West Point and
here he is reviewing cadets during visit
to Academy of Britain's popular Prince
of Wales who also saw service in France
MacArthur's command of West Point is as
brilliant as his record as student there his
scholastic average highest in points history